hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whose line if you saw
whose line is it anyway we're doing the
same thing we've got a little bits of
paper that you guys wrote and tweet it
out to us and we're going to do some
basic improv with basic scene works but
we have to inject these lines into some
occasional places we have no idea how
it's going to go because we've never
done it before - Ethan its anticipation
canopy the desire that we should do this
so we're gonna do this we also like to
do a brother so are you ready ready all
right whoever is in that seat weight
seat is going to decide what we're doing
you are bakers and you're in early and
you're just trying to get all the stuff
ready to open the shop so tired Frank we
got to stop pulling these waiting max
don't seem worth this flour sugar spice
something that is worse something else
let me look at the rest I'll attend yeah
what does it say what does it say
blueberries have feelings too
and I I would be happy if you respected
that [ __ ] berries but man [ __ ] blueberry
we need to stop putting them in the
doughnut [ __ ] blueberries
I'm putting them in everything they have
feelings when you kill them they feel it
I know that's what I like about I like
killing things specifically blueberries
I don't want to seem like I'm a murderer
I think I like killing blueberries I
want to be very specific about that but
[ __ ] those blueberries I can't stand the
way they scream I know wow you know what
they say to me in the turns the nights
when I'm stabbing them and
screaming at me you know what they say
freaking frack the snick sack is back
snick sack is back no I'm coming for the
looters it's me I'm the snick snack you
know why I was doing those late nights
stickin I was snacking not on
blueberries oh I'm more than the
blueberries you think the world is just
about blueberries I thought it was about
her tonight so naive what is this world
in Donuts there's more you're right
sharks are not supposed to fall from the
sky who are you to tell the snick snack
what he and she cannot do that's right
I'm both hey don't you dare tell me
sharks can't fall from the sky I started
this donut shop I bought the first flour
one where the blueberries window never
in the shop you ever read the shop
slogan this impose no your own matatus
it's a wonderful phrase you telling me I
need to open my hood donut shop and not
make blueberries or that I'm supposed to
it's kind of one of the real open
interpretation slogans you know I wanted
it to inspire people or something like
that like I said I don't want to kill
anybody my blueberries I made that very
clear in the beginning this I'm not a
murderer
I am what would I say before I kill what
my mom would makes weird sounds at night
oh that's sex are you having sex with my
mom oh god no I literally just killed
blueberries I don't do anything else
wrong the snick snack is really not that
bad a villain Chicago fun at night I do
not know did you bully money probably
your dad if I had to guess he's alive
and see more joy he's the bartender you
know really well you guys they're like
really good friends cuz you always get
drunk together so Bobby you'll have the
usual I presume make it a double
you're getting fired tomorrow oh sorry
hear that why does that happen well I
may have groped my boss's daughter look
that is a lot worse than I thought you
were gonna say I don't know if she's his
daughter right but her last names the
same and when I got to the house his car
was there so I was like I should bail on
this maybe you should have bailed on
them anyway I'm pretty sure he's gonna
be pissed about it
he's gay yeah you might you might get
fired but you might also get killed
that's impossible I mean I don't know if
he saw me like I we walked we walked up
I ran when I realized it was his car but
he yelled out the front door like as I
was running away yeah go outside and
talk to a tree make friends with the
tree there's nothing wrong with having a
tree's a friend no it seems like a
ridiculous thing it's safer Traynham
maybe he was trying to get away from his
daughter you know have be friends with
the tree no my daughter kind of thing
yeah certainly scared me off hmm
anything you know it could go either way
maybe he was just trying to be
encouraging and he was sad I was leaving
uh I could be optimistic yeah big unit
his daughter found someone right huh
that's possible yeah he wanted you to be
friends with the trees I was in similar
scenario one time and I was I I was
frightened icing with a with my with my
friend's daughter and he told me he told
me she make my cheese melt just like my
heart he said that to me it's right
inside that's you
yeah you must have been all out of sorts
if you're fern izing with his dog how
old was his daughter oh maybe it's a
cultural thing maybe I didn't do
anything wrong
both of us went the same way apparently
uh what happened I know you know he
wanted you to be with the trees he
wanted me to be with the cheese what I
blame public schools okay it's not my
fault she's attractive and God my job
sucks and she was what am I supposed to
do you know what my health teacher told
me about sex this is how backwards
public education is mom this is the real
mr. Pinker my health my sex ed class was
just a health teacher just Marcia in
front of the class and just put on a
video and when it finished she just went
I have a lovely bunch of coconuts and
walked out that was it what I suppose
power I don't know how to interact I
know you Chi Kok yeah that's what I
thought tonight I can see every time
those go yeah mrs. Johnson she was old
but you know you could tell you could
tell she had experience yeah anyway
sing okay you're you're burying your dog
continue the whole nephew Processing's
guy it was a dumb dog it was it he was a
great dog
fine it was a great dog yeah I know
maybe drunk a little bit right it was a
little bit of a that's cuz you gave on
the alcohol yeah I mean it was yelling
all the time I decided to give him home
but you know it's okay it's a learning
experience that's it good that was just
a wrong okay I think you're fine I've
been drinking a lot I could tell them
about fighting biker biker thanks for
pronouncing
originally a little dream - oh you're a
fly car maker - you know you're one of
the family and I'm here to help you
through that you want to knit I don't
know what that means
thank you hey strange tricky but you
know your uncle's a strange man you are
a cool [ __ ] you're like oh man
you remember what Fido used to save me
long ago
you're the only one you never talk to
yeah that weird power I have too
talkative dogs done come in handy
otherwise how to shut that dog up anyway
he used to say to me way back when oh
man it was just a pup hello everybody my
name is markiplier that [ __ ] done
wouldn't shut you up I said that but you
know I never would say yeah I said it he
said yeah I said whole bunch wouldn't
stop saying it kept messing it up - yep
saying it over and over again ah [ __ ]
you fight him mom told me she couldn't
be here she to work but she told me to
say a few words - fine but she wrote
down what she wanted to say so let me
before we move on let me just say what
she wanted wanted to get out with a long
[ __ ] line she said I'm sorry it was
just really heavy I can understand how
your dog now she said on a scale from 1
to America how free are you tonight
you're very free for you they're so
afraid about you you know I know you
always wanted to be whatever a
markiplier is just our puppy I love you
mine alone and so he's all the way to
America everybody on that scale that's
pretty free that is pretty good smegal
good level when you can not love gets me
in jail Micah Micah can't go back I will
tell this time it's okay
you're hurting a bit I can tell you but
before you drink
remember my own drinking phone hmm
please revive me I forgot oh let's do it
together all right I love blowing up dog
blowing them to hell and down and back
put the TNT in the brave one the wire
over here three Capri to Billy here we
[ __ ] go Oh his head still their last
name I've never seen that I think he
just said his name is markiplier a
shuttle [ __ ] off you little dog fire is
that the normal way you buried a local
biker biker yes that's the fico
microwave now come on but I always
thought I loved blowing up dogs fire
bugger you forgot one thing what our
family motto for racing the family song
we have to say the family motto together
the family motto is please don't go in
the basement
blowing up dog I'll go down to the
basement so anyway that was whose line
which is like unrepentant least don't
why my name is I thought we were gonna
play some okay so that was whose line uh
this is the first improv thing that
we've actually done I mean the don't
laughing is kind of improv we're
improvising what we do but this is the
first like structure you okay buddy so
we hope you enjoyed it we have no idea
how it's going to turn out hopefully
it's gonna be good uh and thank you all
for participating if you want to see
this again or a different variety of it
there's like different games that we
could do like the change game where you
doing the scene and then you say chain
and you have to change this done yeah we
could just mix and match so let us know
down in the comments below thanks again
everybody for watching and as always
we'll see you in the next video bye bye
you
[Music]